hi there Steve Kaufman here again time
to do a video I put up some of these
interviews that I've done with people
like look Moses Richard and Felix very
often people say do one in this language
or that language or they ask for
subtitles as so far as it sub tonnes are
concerned I simply don't have the time
to do them so there won't be subtitles
if you have specific requests maybe
people can vote on them what language
they want to hear who they want me to
talk to people have also suggest that I
speak to Professor argh Elias I'm gonna
try to do that maybe someone can help me
make a connection there so if those are
popular I'll continue to doing them I
think they're great because you know
before the YouTube we had no idea that
there were so many people out there that
could speak so many different languages
and I'm sure that the few people that
I've spoken to are just the tip of the
iceberg there's many many more you know
as I've said before once you get past
your second language and your third
language every successive language
becomes easier to do from many points of
view including and this is the subject
of my discussion today including the
aspect of pronunciation I certainly
worked harder on getting my
pronunciation you know as close to
native as possible in say French and
then Chinese than I have done in
subsequent languages because I think
that that the brain gets more
comfortable and gets more used to
different sounds a wider range of sounds
that the more languages we learn the
that control that the first language
exercises on your brain becomes watered
down as you're exposed to a greater
variety of sounds and even structures
and so forth and so on now the question
is is it realistic is it even a smart
thing to do to try to sound like a
native okay now as I've often said you
know language learning is all about
enjoy
so if you enjoy trying to sound like a
native by all means you know do so but I
think that the idea of trying to sound
like a native you know at two levels if
it's your goal in other words it's the
model like I would like to swing a golf
club like Tiger Woods that's fine if you
actually expect to sound like a native
or expect to hit the golf ball like
Tiger Woods
I think that's unrealistic and I think
it's a distraction I have other than
people who grow up bilingual from you
know at least their teens if not early
childhood I can't think of many people I
speak to in English who sound like a
native there was one fellow that I
listened to on anti moon a number of
years ago who I thought was really good
with his American accent we had a fellow
at our forum at link from Russia from
st. Petersburg who's whose English was
very close to native and you have to
listen closely but inevitably something
will give them away you know it's
possible that if I phone a Japanese
restaurant or a French restaurant or a
Chinese restaurant
and I asked for a table and there's lots
of dishes clanging in the background
that the person on the other end of the
phone may think that I'm a native or
won't even ask himself or herself the
question but if I get in a conversation
with someone they will know that I'm not
a native
you know Luka who sounds to me like a
native in German French Spanish doesn't
sound like a native to me in English so
you know is that because he's better in
those other languages or is it because
you know the only real test of whether
you're sound like a native is whether a
native thinks you sound like a native
and as I say I rarely hear anyone get
the odd very bilingual person especially
in in Quebec people have grown up
surrounded by
English I mean the coach of our
professional hockey team in Vancouver
Island he knew I mean he sounds to me
just about like a native but you can
kind of pick out a few things that are
good different but he's essentially he
sounded like a native but he's been
living in English for a long long time
the idea that you can sound like a
native in several languages I think it
is highly unlikely it's also a
distraction because ultimately it
doesn't matter you know I the other day
someone put on our format Linga a link
to a certain mr. Vaughn who runs
language schools in Spain and I'll put
the link up on my blog he speaks Spanish
flawlessly
I mean his use of words is excellent you
know I was just in awe of his Spanish
but I can tell that he's not a native
and I know that Spanish people can tell
that he's not a native and it doesn't
matter it doesn't detract from his
Spanish in any way I mean Henry
Kissinger spoke with an obvious accent
but he used the language very well so to
me you know speaking like a native a
it's highly unlikely that you're gonna
achieve it so it's nice to have as a
model you know reach for the sky but
it's highly likely that you are going to
achieve it it's far more important in my
mind to have a good command of the
language I mean if you go and talk to
someone and in the first five seconds
they think they're native but after I
mean you're not you know you we don't
use the language just to communicate in
five-second bullets we want to have our
genuine exchange quite often quite
honestly if I'm communicating with
someone in the language I don't care
whether he thinks I'm a native I want to
have a good you know conversation with
the person so the impression I create in
the first five seconds of the
conversation really doesn't matter to me
it doesn't matter to me whether someone
in a restaurant with enough background
noise thinks that I'm a native speaker
of Japanese it really doesn't matter
when I'm with Japanese people
I just want to communicate and nothing
to is that so much of language learning
is is about discovering the language
discovering the culture learning
about the country learning about the
history discovering the language
learning to understand the language so
much of of language learning is taking
it in language is not a performance
sport where we're judged on how you know
how good the dive was in diving or you
know like figure skating that's not what
it is it's it's understanding
discovering exploring and communicating
so unless you have such a bad accent
that the native speaker can't understand
you trying to imitate I mean as I say
yes it's the model but we don't expect
we don't expect to achieve it now we
would all like to improve our accent to
some degree and so what can we do and
some people say you should sing if you
like singing sing I personally don't do
that but there's obviously nothing wrong
with doing that one thing that I found
useful was you know listening and then
recording myself and then comparing
initially with words and then with
phrases and then with paragraphs and
then putting a lot of emphasis on
intonation as many people point out
intonation is very key there's this word
prosody or whatever I don't use it
because I don't like strange words that
I've never come across before but
intonation works fine for me rhythm
music intonation the flow of the
language I think a lot of you know
listening and and recording and
comparing can help us as well as a lot
of a lot of listening period I think
language learning as I've said before I
made a few notes here because I was I
was working out while listening to check
and yet thinking about this thing and
then I'd get off the treadmill and
scribble down some notes get back on my
treadmill while the check podcast was
blaring in the background but what else
did I say here yeah my attorney is more
of a holistic thing it's listening it's
reading it's discovering it's speaking
it's working on vocabulary it's working
on a number of things including
intonation and rhythm and the more of
all of these pieces that you that start
to come together the better you are in
the language and probably the better
your accent will become and some people
will do better than others in accent but
it's me to try and deliberately you know
attempt to sound like a native
vertically
that you sound like a native to me as I
say is just a distraction from language
honey what else did I have to say yeah I
mean the main thing is I want people to
communicate with me
I want to be able to speak well enough
in terms of my accent and turns of my
use of language that the native speaker
doesn't make any special allowances
debate the native speaker doesn't say
I'm talking to some foreigner here who
has trouble expressing himself and I
can't understand what he's saying
I want the native speaker to just say
this is Steve X it doesn't matter what
is you know nationality or language of
origin is we're communicating and he has
something to say that's of interest and
he's able to express himself or he what
he says is dumb and I'm gonna tell him
he's dumb but either way we are
communicating so I mean basically there
you have it I mean you know Richard and
I both speak French very well Richard
Simchat as this luca better than both of
them better than i do I'm sure but I
don't think people would I can't speak
for Luca because I don't know he might
be taken for native I don't know I don't
think Richard and/or I would be taken
for a native in our French but we both
speak the language very well and I think
that's really all you have to achieve so
thank you for listening bye for now